[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zu einer neuen ausgabe filmnacht
es ist donnerstagabend meine großartigen
gäste heute abend sind der richter
andreas müller bekannt geworden ist er
für seine harten urteile gegen junge
straftäter berüchtigt ist er für seinen
kampf für die legalisierung von cannabis
erste zitat wer heute noch sagt cannabis
eine einstiegsdroge muss ausgelacht
werden so sade gastautoren bei der welt
sie war lange jahre für die zeit tätig
und spd oberbürgermeisterin ihrer
heimatstadt kiel sie fragt sich heute
abend wer trägt die verantwortung für
den vereitelten amoklauf und essen oder
heute in bremerhaven agent leben ist
eine der erfolgreichsten gründerinnen
dieses landes während ihrer
schwangerschaft hat sich das berliner
architekt willi mitgegründet dass 2021
mit 640 millionen dollar bewertet wurde
und trotzdem sagt sie deutschlands
innovation schwäche gefährdet unseren
wohlstand ich bin sehr gespannt reif
andreas müller ist journalist beim
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk und
tritt aktiv den judenhass entgegen er
möchte über das tabu thema
antisemitismus sprechen und warum die
täter geschützt werden und damit
herzlich willkommen bei 48 mein name ist
der schick und ich darf heute ihre
gastgeberin sein mich hat heute auch ein
thema sehr bewegt und dieses thema ist
eigentlich ein sehr persönliches was ich
auch sehr traurig macht den stellen sie
sich vor sie selbst krank sie haben
gerade eine schwierige diagnose bekommen
und werden das krankenhaus eingeliefert
ich habe das zum glück nicht aber viele
menschen diesem land haben dass sie
geben selbstverständlich ihren liebsten
bescheid und die wollen auch direkt zu
ihnen kommen aber das krankenhaus
verwehrt den einlass der grund die
korona bestimmung ich möchte ihnen hier
ein paar beispiele geben dem uniklinikum
essen ist nur eine person pro tag pro
patient erlaubt in den sana kliniken in
düsseldorf ist es noch schlimmer in
duisburg dort ist nur ein besucher pro
patient erlaubt und das nur für eine
stunde das heißt sie müssten dann
entscheiden ob ihr geht jetzt der vater
geht die tochter und das nur für 60
minuten am tag das war's den helios
kliniken in duisburg es extra noch
erwähnt dass kindern der zutritt als
begleitperson derzeit nicht gestattet
ist ich kann nicht verstehen wie das als
gesellschaft erlauben können wie die
politik das tolerieren kann ich bin mir
bewusst ist bei den betreibern das
hausrecht gilt aber ich finde dass wir
auf begehren müssen die bewohner
beschränkung in den krankenhäusern sind
für mich ein verbrechen
ja das stimmt also ich hab selber gerade
erlebt ich musste mich einer operation
unterziehen und am morgen vor der op
also nüchtern wenn man da etwas
aufgeregt ein scheck wurde mir erst mal
gesagt ja hier herrscht besuchsverbot
also hier darf gar keiner kommen niemand
niemand die ganze zeit über nicht und es
hat er auch niemand für nötig gehalten
einen darüber mal auf zu klein ich kann
verstehen dass gerade die betreiber von
kliniken natürlich sorge haben wenn sich
jetzt wieder in kona ausbruch haben wenn
ihr personal krank wird das dann
natürlich viel dran hängt aber ich
glaube wir haben es auch mit einer
mentalität zu tun
die sich bestimmte abkürzungen angewöhnt
hat in der kuchener zeit bestimmte
regelungen die für chefs für
organisatoren angenehm sind das gilt
übrigens nicht nur für kliniken auch für
den ganzen dienstleistungsbereich wurde
immer noch so ist dass man sozusagen
bestimmte sachen jetzt vor schreibt die
überhaupt nicht mehr nötig sind und ich
glaube wir brauchen jetzt echt mal ein
umdenken nach kroner und einfach mal neu
gucken was ist jetzt wirklich
existenziell nötig und was ist einfach
faulheit und frechheit ich fand es auch
sehr schockierend weil wir haben auch
gerade einen fall und dann habe ich dort
angerufen und dann meinte schon mal
stressig mehr bitte besorgt die
sondergenehmigung damit wir beiden hin
dürfen und da muss man sich schon ganz
klar fragen da habe ich mich schon
ziemlich beschissen gefühlt dass ich in
meiner kleinen schwester sagen was ja
hoffentlich bekommen wir beide die
sondergenehmigung war ansonsten können
eine von uns hin oder niemand aus der
familie also eine person dafür aber wer
geht dann und mich hat das dann so sehr
beschäftigt dass ich das heute abend
auch mitgebracht habe und diese
verschiedenen kliniken gemacht habe was
ich mich nur frage und jetzt zwei
juristen am tisch es ist jetzt nicht das
juristische thema es ist ja auch die
hausordnung der betreiber aber kann man
nicht irgendetwas juristisch dagegen tun
frau sachtleber hat das ist eine gemeine
frage gleich zum auftakt ja mein
jurastudium ist eine weile her und ich
bin garantiert in ihrem haus recht wie
corona fragen
führen
persönlich finde ich jetzt auch absurd
diese ganze thema
das ist eine regelung die wurde glaube
ich 2020 eingeführt und spiegelt aber
überhaupt nicht mehr das wieder wo wir
jetzt im infektionsgeschehen sind also
ich meine situation sondern von allen
starts ich weiß
weiß also ich bevor wir die juristen das
machen würde er an den gesunden
menschenverstand appellieren der kann
nicht besser
ich habe das bereits 2020 mal geprüft
also da waren menschen die konten nicht
zu ihrem schwer kranken leuten an sich
nicht verabschieden sich nicht
verabschieden obwohl sie wussten sie
sterben in einem tag natürlich geprüft
das kann doch nicht sein das darf doch
nicht sein das ist doch das wichtigste
für menschen ja noch von den geliebten
abschied zu nehmen da spielt natürlich
alles mögliche reihenhaus ordnung wer
ist träger des krankenhaus wer ist
träger des heims und so weiter also ich
persönlich würde mir das antun würde ich
würde klagen bis zum
bundesverfassungsgericht und zwar mit
ein zwei ligen anordnung sollten die das
regeln das geht nicht es gibt nicht nur
die körperliche gesundheit es gibt auch
noch die psyche
aber sie haben sich den betreiber ja
ausgesucht wie das kommt drauf an das
kommt darauf an da geben wir jetzt in
die tiefen der juristerei haben die
möglicherweise eine monopolstellung
müssen ja auf irgendeine art diesen
kranken dem betreuten übernehmen da gibt
es ganz ganz viele wir könnten sie eine
deutlich situation darüber schreiben ich
persönlich halte das was jetzt auch noch
gemacht wird ja die beschränkungen für
nicht mehr vernünftig herr müller sie
arbeiten ja auch beim öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk wie sieht die
debatte dort aus also wir sind schon
hier am tisch ja wie man auch merkt sehr
stark gegen diese bestimmungen wird
diese debatte auch geführt bei ihnen in
der redaktion die debatte wird natürlich
auch geführt aber kontrovers und die
wird nicht nur bei uns geführt die wird
denke ich in allen medien äußeren
geführt und zwar nicht nur im öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk sondern auch bei
den printmedien und in anderen häuser es
gibt keine man kann ich sagen dass da
eine konkrete feste meinung ja aber es
gibt eben ein sehr obrigkeitliche
verhalten auch nicht also wenn man der
nacht haben sie das mal so das hat ja
auch einen effekt und ich denke ihr
schwerer mann hast desto schlimmer es
hat ja auch ein effekt auf die
heilungschancen dass man sich also bis
hinten vorn und aufgehoben fühlt dort
und ich frage mich dann häufig auch beim
personal also wenn man dann sagt aber
ist das jetzt klug ist es wird nötig
wenn man also zum beispiel die charité
soweit ich weiss macht es mit tests und
masken das ist dann aufwändig darf
kommen und ich versuche ja zu schützen
wo es wo es dann geht das kommt sehr
häufig so von mitarbeitern na ja das ist
so angeordnet wie schön die unangenehme
gefühl meine bestimmung ist und ich will
natürlich ist es in vielen fällen ist es
einfacher und wir haben das bei hotels
bei fluglinien bei der bahn bei vielen
bestimmungen sozusagen sehen sie jetzt
auch da ist es nicht so schlimm da ist
es dann mehr ärgerlich und unbequem hier
ist es existenziell zum teil und ich wir
brauchen das zeigt auch wieder wir sind
als gesellschaft noch nicht durch mit
dem thema kokona wir müssen noch mal
drüber reden was war vernünftig was war
überzogen was war unvernünftig und auch
ein bisschen wer hat sozusagen
unverhältnismäßig viel angst gemacht und
uns sozusagen eingeschüchtert das ist
nicht aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir
noch machen besteht die chance dass
aufgearbeitet wird also muss es muss
also ich setze sind ja immer auf das
politische instrument tatsächlich der
enquete-kommission weil ich finde das
gehört auf die bundestags eben auch bei
der bundestag sich selber als parlament
am anfang so fürchterlich rausgenommen
hat also so fürchte nicht alles an die
exekutive an die regierung delegiert hat
und im grunde nicht anständig darüber
diskutiert darüber mit mit
scheindebatten die gar nicht ernst
gemeint war das muss eigentlich da auf
großer bühne noch einmal verhandelt
werden es gibt ja viele auch in den
medien viele akteure die sagen das
sollte so sein das ist notwendig aber
wir müssen jetzt dranbleiben wir sind
natürlich jetzt durch ein nächstes
großes
mitreißendes und schlimmes geschehen
nämlich die demokratie kriegt natürlich
auch wieder gefangen genommen und
gefesselt und wir dürfen glaube ich
dieses große thema und was ist mit
unserer gesellschaft kann das dürfen wir
nicht vergessen also ich glaube sie
wesentlich ist zu sagen dass man das
panikmache kein guter ist also panik
hilft nicht das haben wir jetzt in den
zwei jahren auch erlebt panik schüren
hilft nicht sondern wie sie richtig
sagen mit augenmaß und ich im medien
haben auch panik gefährten ja wir haben
alle fehler gemacht also wir sind ja
alle von dieser welle wäre waren um
vorbereitet wir wussten nicht was auf
uns zukommt und ich denke wir sind alle
ein bisschen klüger geworden und ich
habe auch die hoffnung dass das jetzt
noch mehr mit augenmaß wissen
eine sache über die wir auch debattieren
müssen die heute passiert auch wieder
die gerade in steigender zahl
passiert sind die amokläufe und da hast
du uns gebracht zu sein ja wir haben ja
jetzt gerade die situation in
bremerhaven gehabt
man merkt finde ich an dieser stelle
auch wir haben jetzt wieder sagen über
zwei jahre lang in einer
ausnahmesituation gelebt also kona hat
als thema alles dominiert und jetzt
dominiert natürlich der ukraine krieg
alles auch zu sich man hat ja das gefühl
alle anderen sorgen und probleme sind
ein bisschen kleiner im verhältnis zu
seinem elend das da stattfindet aber die
ganze gesellschaft mit all ihren
problemen ihrem leid ihrem kummer ihren
schwierigkeiten und ihren verbrechen
lebt halt weiter und das sind 83
millionen menschen die dafür die findet
leben statt jeden tag und leider eben
auch immer mal wieder diese
ausnahmesituationen das ist ja sozusagen
fast in einem rhythmus von zehn jahren
also passieren diese dinge also das ist
schulmassaker von erfurt winnenden das
war 2009 jetzt haben wir den aktuellen
fall was all diesen sachen gemeinsam ist
das war ja auch beim zoll und ein
massaker in den usa wo das ist natürlich
das waffenrecht alles immer noch
schlimmer aber auch bei dem
schrecklichen massaker in norwegen in
utoya es sind taten von männern es sind
häufig einzelgänger sie sind oft im netz
in einer schwierigen weise unterwegs und
im unglücklichen fall haben sie im
zugang zu waffen den sie so nicht haben
sollten das ist bei uns schon sehr sehr
viel besser geregelt als es etwa den usa
ist aber trotzdem ist natürlich mit den
sportwaffen immer noch ein gewaltiges
risiko in der gesellschaft das heißt man
müsste schon gucken kann man nicht doch
den zugang zur sportwaffen so
beschränken dass die nur im verein
greifbar sind da sagen die sportvereine
immer sofort es geht nicht gut ich sehe
auch die probleme aber dass sie zuhause
rumliegen und dann der waffenschrank
nicht ordentlich gesichert ist dass es
halt auch eine katastrophe und wir
kommen hat das wäre sozusagen mein
wichtigster punkt politisch kann man nur
begrenzt sozusagen gegen diese art von
katastrophen und schickt also unglücke
tun
aber eltern müssen natürlich einen
wachen blick auf ihre kinder haben und
ich weiß wie schwer das ist gerade mit
der netznutzung also wenn ein junge von
19 im netz unterwegs ist das kriegt ja
dann die gelernte bibliothekarin oder so
möglicherweise wirklich nicht mit oder
eine englischlehrerin oder was weiß ich
aber man muss ein gesprächs verhältnis
zu seinen kindern haben und gerade in
diesem fall nun wirklich zu den jungs
und dann muss man auch gucken also was
ist mit frei beweglichen waffen in
meinem haushalt das kann sehr familie
niemand abnehmen also politik kann
helfen ist es gut dass wir jetzt diese
sicherheitstrainings schulen haben dass
die also wissen wie sie sich jetzt
verhalten sollen wenn das war ja wohl
heute auch der fall also tür zu also die
nicht die klassen dann auch zum teil
sind die räume von außen nicht mehr zu
öffnen das ist alles gut aber die letzte
verantwortung und das letzte aufpassen
das ist in der familie zu hause es ist
ja eigentlich wirklich schrecklich dass
wir diese sicherheitstrainings in
schulen haben ja das ist ja das ist ja
zeigt die absurdität dieser verhältnisse
dass wir unseren kindern beibringen
müssen was man machen muss wenn ein
amokläufer
kommt ja und ich denke auch dass es
wichtig ist was die eltern was die
eltern machen die eine große
verantwortung aber ich sehe die
wanderung auch bei den schulen die
schulen ist die lebenswirklichkeit
dieser kinder und wir wissen auch dass
solche themen wie mobbing und ein
problematisches selbstwertgefühl gerade
junge männer dazu hin leitet zu
attentätern zu werden und dass dieses
mobbing findet in der schule statt und
in social netzwerken und da brauchen wir
da auch da ausgebildete pädagogen die
das abfangen können ja und die da
schneller angebote haben weil ich weiss
nicht den eltern das jetzt auch noch
aufzuladen es ist ein bisschen viel aber
natürlich sind die eltern auch da in der
pflicht dazu schauen also irgendjemand
es ja immer schuld sind sie eltern sind
die sozialarbeiter haben wir nicht
genügend gemacht im vorfeld und so
weiter ich glaube wir leben in
deutschland schon ganz gut eben auch
wegen deren wegen der vernünftigen
waffen politik die wir hier haben und
jetzt wieder nach verschärfung von
gesetzen zur ruhe man
ja aber wir werden das allgemeine
lebensrisiko
nicht auf null bringen ich glaube dass
unsere gesellschaft immer so denkt
allgemeines lebensrisiko
einfach bis hinein natürlich nicht das
ist schon richtig in der schule muss man
aufpassen
der jugendrichter muss auch aufpassen
und viele institutionen müssen aufpassen
einer kirche und und und und es wird ja
auch ganz viel aufgepasst aber ich
glaube nicht aufgepasst ja in der schule
ganz viele sozialarbeiter gucken können
die mit schülergruppen auch es ist das
thema ist der in der gesellschaft drin
es ist sensibilisiert und so weiter
gleichwohl werden wir nicht jeden fall
in den kommenden zehn jahren verhindern
ich habe nach er fordert auch per
tausende von diskussionen gegeben wie
werden wir alles verhindern ich glaube
wir stehen in der bundesrepublik
deutschland noch sehr gut da trotzdem
ist es richtig dass man diskutiert
deshalb ist es wichtig das zu besprechen
sind die regeln richtig sind wir einer
richtigen balance zwischen
zu akzeptieren das ist ein lebensrisiko
gibt zu was kann man alles noch machen
was machen andere länder wie stehen wir
im vergleich also ich finde das ist
schon eine wichtige diskussion dass
heute dieses dieser vorfall bremerhaven
das ist schrecklich da in eine frau
schwer verletzt worden ja wir sollten
das diskutieren ohne panik wie sie herr
müller schon gesagt haben aber mit den
fakten und vor allem also ich denke auch
dass das strikte waffenrecht in
deutschland und frau gesehen und total
recht es sind häufig die sportwaffen
weil irgendwie einer familie
sportschütze ist und die jugendlichen
die gerade in diesen schwierigen phasen
sind und sich dann sozusagen auch
versteht also in diese richtung
entwickeln film net eventuell unterwegs
sind damit in kontakt kommen die dürfen
auf gar keinen fall zugang zu waffen
haben und mir geht es auch nicht um
schuld eigentlich also dass das das
macht dann gleich den ganzen kontext
negativ also ich glaube ein punkt ist
sicher richtig da haben sie völlig recht
also die die schulen müssen sicher bei
mobbing also noch genauer hingucken das
ist einfach ein unangenehmes thema da
hat man sofort als mit irgendwelchen
eltern hat man dann immer ärger und als
lehrer ist das nicht dankbar nicht also
am ende hatten eine als lehrer wenn man
da eingegriffen hat insofern kann ich
das auch verstehen aber da glaube ich
eine höhere sensibilität gerade nochmal
raster im internet veranstaltet wird
auch wirklich an becks temming und
fürchterlichen sachen also dass das ist
wichtig ich würde nicht schuld sein
sondern chance ich glaube die eltern
haben dann doch die beste chance zu
wissen was mit ihrem kind so los ist und
man muss halt sprechen sprechen sprechen
das ist wirklich eine anforderung und da
kann man immer sagen zu müde zu viel
arbeit zu langer tag für viele stunden
ja auch in der einrichtung die die
jungen leute oder die kinder sowieso und
etwas älteren jugendlichen auch aber
trotzdem wer soll denn miteinander
sprechen können wenn nicht eltern und
kinder und deswegen also ich glaube es
ist es nicht waren sich originell als
vorschlag aber man muss es einfach immer
wieder sagen es gibt zb einen roman
einer amerikanischen autorin landes
weiter heißt die let's talk about kevin
das ist ein schöner roman wo die autorin
sehr also sehr empfehlenswert einfach
auch vielleicht für eltern die sich
meinen gesang auf deutsch ich weiß es
nicht genau den deutschen titel aber
eltern die sich vielleicht so ein
bisschen sorgen machen was ist mit
meinem kind weil da kann man einfach mal
so ein bisschen die muster sind da in
literarischer form verarbeitet da kann
man viel aber ein bisschen gucken wie
kommen also wie komme ich an wieder ins
gespräch oder brauchen wir wacher und
rollern schulen nein nein
entschuldigen sie
via taschenkontrollen dies und jenes
susan beglaubigt können bin denn waren
machen es gegebenenfalls vor der schule
oder sonstwo
also was wir auf keinen fall brauchen
irgendwelche verschärfungen des klimas
und verschärfung von gesetzen das
brauchen wir nicht wir brauchen besseres
aufpassen vielleicht hier und da und was
natürlich wichtig ist wir müssen gucken
wenn jemand tatsächlich gemobbt wird
dann müssen andere institutionen
eingreifen die eltern schafften es
manchmal einfach nicht erschaffen sind
was denn wirklich mobbing oft der grund
es war ja dass wir für amokläufe also
soweit ich informiert bin
waren ja oft nicht der faktor mobbing
auslöser sondern sondern andere dinge
und ich finde ich glaube was sie gesagt
haben frau sein leben ist auch wichtig
hin zu gucken bei eltern pädagogen und
so weiter und vorzeichen also soziale
netzwerke oft werden diese sachen ja
angekündigt dass man da genau hinguckt
und ja die ersten warenzeichen wahrnimmt
das wird ja auch viel verhindert schon
weil leute hinkommen aber eine sache
frage ich mich schon warum laufen nur
jungs amok
warum sind 90 prozent aller gewalttäter
bei mir männlich ja warum ja weil sie
irgendwie sich anders irgendwie
ausdrücken müssen
ich habe in meinem leben geweiht der
eine einzige und ich lebe schon 30 jahre
als jugend und strafrichter nur eine
einzige dame junge dame natürlich weg
spielen müssen sonst waren es immer
männer ja warum machen möchten wichtig
tun wir müssen auf irgendeine art stark
sein die wollen sich irgendwie behaupten
der frau auch gegenüber behaupten ich
bin stark ich weiß es nicht das liegt in
den genen denke ich
wo es auch darum geht leute abzuziehen
man braucht geld für klamotten usw ich
habe er menschen die klauen irgendwelche
klamotten damit sie schön sein aber beim
angreifer tatsächlich ist das
tatsächlich anders also ja da sind für
viele leute viele jugendliche haben
keine freunde werden gemobbt problem mit
dem selbstwertgefühl
das haben jungs und mädchen oder ja aber
die gehen damit tatsächlich anders nun
mädchen internalisieren dass mehr
verletzen sie ja selber depression
depression angststörungen ritzen jungs
externalisierung ist ja und was man
damit machen das ist das eigentlich de
facto toxische männlichkeit toxicity ja
und das liegt auch daran dass ich denke
dass man beiden männer und frauen jungs
und mädchen therapie anbieten muss und
es glaube ich noch mehr in den
rollenbildern von männern zu sagen in
der therapie gehe ich nicht ja das kann
ich wieder das kann die haben also
insofern ist es glaube ich eine
grundlegende unterschied zwischen
zwischen den geschlechtern hier aber das
wird dadurch verstärkt dass ich glaube
ein jugendlicher anders breivik er im
internet auf den auf den vorgang von
frau rasch wieder zu sprechen das ist
anders motiviert ist also dass jungs an
das ist ja eigentlich schon bei den
eltern liegt weil wenn ich jetzt hier zu
hören ist es ja schon so vielleicht
müssen wir einfach anders erziehen jungs
ja also es ist sich ein komplexes ist
sich ein komplexes problem es sind ja
häufig die opfer dieser dieser gewalt
hatten auch überwiegend mädchen und
frauen also das ist häufig dann auch
noch ein aspekt von frustriert sein weil
man vielleicht keine freundin hat weil
man bei den mädels da nicht landen kann
mit seinem einzelgängertum ganz bestimmt
muss man die jungs in der erziehung noch
viel mehr zum reden bringen als die
mädchen mädchen reden ja also frauen
lösen der probleme ist sozusagen häufig
über kommunikation bei männern gibt es
halt diese blöde alte gewalt optionen
noch nicht und insofern wird die dann
auch gezogen wenn man sozusagen ausser
sich geriet und in einer psychischen
ausgewählten sein und wir diskutieren ja
auch die ganze zeit daheim natürlich
eine sehr weibliche erziehung also sehr
sehr viele alleinerziehende sozusagen
wurde natürlich die kinder dann doch
immer noch traditionell war der mutter
sind kindergärtnerinnen
grundschullehrerin insgesamt die
lehrerschaft hat sich auch verweichlicht
in den letzten jahrzehnten das wird ja
manchmal auch diskutiert also sozusagen
bräuchten die jungs eher positive
männliche vorbilder wo ein bisschen
gerangelt dann im prinzip auch mal okay
ist aber eben mann massakriert an
nichtig das ist das sind natürlich nie
direkte zusammenhänge das ist nie eine
direkte kausalität aber noch mal darüber
nachzudenken wie erziehen wir jungs in
dieser gesellschaft das ist glaube ich
dringend angesagt es gibt viel zu tun da
sehen wir vor allem weil man schon das
gefühl die gesellschaft dieses kurs geht
es fast nur um die mädchen wir sollten
die jungs nicht vergessen und der müll
also neben gesetze sind kein fachmann
für amokläufer aber sind schon fachmann
für cannabis oder würde ich jetzt mal so
ich bin schon dran mit cannabis
große das bundesverfassungsgericht
bereits in mehreren 19 2002 angerufen
jetzt habe ich zusammen mit fünf anderen
richtern angerufener liegen vorlagen die
letzte die ich geschrieben habe
gegenüber 140 seiten das ist fast eine
die situation soll ich jetzt ausführen
warum cannabis legalisiert werden muss
natürlich mache ich das ja wir haben
seit 50 jahren eine provisions politik
ist geschafft hat hunderttausende von
menschen in den knast bringen millionen
von menschen wurden mit geldstrafen
übersät einträge in führungs solchen job
verlust und und und familien wurden
zerstört infolge einer angst die
geschaffen wurde nämlich dadurch dass
man seit den siebziger jahren mit der
einzigste theorie ja argumentiert das
hat das bundesverfassungsgericht im jahr
1994 bereits widerlegt gleichwohl wird
damit argumentiert und raum geschmissen
weltweit vertritt dass kein
wissenschaftler und jetzt ich weiß nicht
ob ich noch zehn sekunden habe oder 20
jetzt müssen wir auf der einen seite
gucken was bringt die prohibition die
hat nichts gebracht und das ist auch
wissenschaftlicher wiesen es wird an
jeder ecke gekifft in jeder haushalt in
jeder
motiven reiche kiffen unternehmer kiffen
jalet raketen staatsanwälte und so
weiter jetzt bringt gar nichts ich
wollte wenn sie jetzt sehen wie viele
leute tatsächlich einen schaden durch
cannabis dabei bei wie vielen und das
wird auch übertrieben bis zum
gehtnichtmehr das sind in etwa
3000 die in stationären
behandlungen sind die sind da aber trotz
der provisions politik und dann jeder
jugendliche kann an jeder ecke was
kriegen und jack reed gestecktes zeug
und es wird teilweise und gestrecktes
verkauf und daran sterben die jugend
weltweit ist an cannabis teil mensch
gestorben
das muss man sich vor augen führt jedes
jahr in deutschland 70.000 tote infolge
von alkoholismus und
verfassungsrechtlich noch ergänzend
warum richter das vor ist der
allgemeinen gleichheitsgrundsatz
tangiert man darf sich taufen man darf
sich sogar umbringen nach der neuesten
verfassungsrechtlichen rechtsprechung
aber wenn sie vor dem umbringen ja und
das andere scheitert denn als versuch ja
zwei gramm cannabis rauchen werden sie
anschließend bestraft das ist das
gleiche wie anfang der 90er jahre in
london wurden sie für den versuchten für
den versuchten suizid mit der
todesstrafe bedroht ich möchte gern denn
für ein unsinn die gleise ich hab ja
eigentlich gehofft dass sie das heute
auch vorsingen aber das möchte ich den
zuschauern
[Musik]
nochmal
kriminalisierung super
dann sagen sie geben für die
entkriminalisierung alles herr müller
und wir geben jetzt mal die frage an
frau was sie davon hält susanne wie
siehst du das mit der legalisierung
also ehrlich gesagt relativ leidenschaft
also ich es ist ja richtig also alkohol
ist sehr gefährlich und alkohol ist
erlaubt und es vermutlich gesundheitlich
tatsächlich deutlich schädlicher als als
cannabis auf der anderen seite kenne ich
natürlich und wir haben gerade über die
problemgruppe der jungs geredet also in
diesem in diesem alter also ende teams
anfang trends mehr jungs würde ich sagen
als mädels die das zeug ziemlich
intensiv nutzen und wo ich das gefühl
das ist für ihre entwicklung jetzt auch
nicht so direkt förderlich ist also die
dann eben sehr so ne scheiß egal
mentalität entwickeln rumhängen eben
ständig alles sehr entspannt sehen und
so weiter was für ihren weiteren
lebensweg nicht unbedingt nützlich ist
ich weiß nicht das kann ich auch nicht
beurteilen so zu sagen wie gefährlich
das ist ich nehme an dass eine ganze
menge eltern ganz froh sind dass sie
noch damit argumentieren können das ist
aber nicht erlaubt natürlich sozusagen
eine gewisse unterstützung bei den
diskussionen darüber ist sie haben
natürlich trotzdem recht die leute
besorgen als ich trotzdem sie sie nutzen
ist trotzdem als liberaler mensch
versucht man immer die
eigenverantwortung hochzuhalten und zu
sagen musst du schnell da ist ja auch
dafür selber also ich hab jetzt ist
keine argumente ich habe kein so richtig
gut ist es voll bei der sache weil ich
ja ja gut das sag ich ja selber
eine frage wäre zb also wenn ich das
richtig sehe hat holland eine relativ
liberale will ja auch mit so oft
cannabis immer gemacht hat jetzt aber
trotzdem relativ massive probleme mit
den drogen merken auch mit anderen
drogen und also insofern dieses leidet
extra oder wenn wir dann haben wir das
erlauben heißt aber nicht weil es ist
aber nicht so zu sagen dass der harte
drogen mag dadurch etwa weg käme oder
oder überflüssig sodass zumindest
ganz interessantes argument und ich
glaube das ist inhaltlich falsch ist
weil das in holland darf man ganz kleine
mengen an cannabis verkaufen das ist
legal und nehme man große mengen
verkauft ist es illegal ja wenn ich
jetzt ein coffeeshop haben in amsterdam
und ich muss große mengen kaufen muss
ich mich sozusagen
mit kriminellen leuten abgeben ja also
ich bin auch total dafür dass man das
legalisiert ich finde es auch gut dass
wir jetzt einen großen
konsultationsprozess anstoßen dass man
das gesellschaftlich breit
aufnimmt der das ist nämlich dessen
wichtige themen weil wie sie frau kaske
ich kann verstehen dass man sagt ich
kenne ich nicht und irgendwie neuen muss
es denn sein ja aber als liberaler
mensch finde ich muss man sagen es gibt
wirklich keinen grund zwischen alkohol
und kiffen alkohol trinken und kiffen
und dann muss man sagen ja das ist das
müssen wir als freiheitliche
gesellschaft außerhalb lässt das der
richtige rückkehr schloss eine frage
wenn man sagt naja alkohol mehr erlaubt
und jetzt sollten wir das auch tun
alkohol schädlich muss man nicht eher
sagen vielleicht sollte man jetzt
aufpassen die nächste droge zu erlauben
habe ich aber noch wir werden sie jetzt
zustimmen allein durch die legalisierung
würde der staat jährlich 1,8 milliarden
euro ein ich bin es macht man das sind
4,5 milliarden ach ja durch einsparungen
in der justiz durch steuern und und habe
daher einen 1,8 das sind reine steuer
aber sie haben auf der anderen seite
haben sie ja die möglichkeit ja bei der
polizei einzusparen wir haben die
möglichkeit die leute in den knästen
besser zu behandeln sie sparen hier und
da ein das sind nur anfangs schätzung
sie schaffen darüber hinaus auch
arbeitsplätze bereits jetzt sind viele
arbeitsplätze da im cbd bereich in
amerika gibt es ganz legale
arbeitsplätze da ist ein vernünftiger
jugendschützer ausbildung was da alles
mit einhergeht und sie schaffen endlich
eine pflanze auf unserem boden wie die
jahrhunderte und jahrtausende lang
gewachsen ist cannabis ist ein
wunderbares eine wunderbare pflanze und
dann könnten bäume stehen lassen wenn
sie holz brauchen machen sie sagt man da
bist sie denn lieber dass sie alkohol
trinken aber nicht dürften natürlich im
zweifel nein ich bin trinken wie wir
alles sagen der handfläche oder sagen
wir den langsam zu dem argument
einstiegsdroge da brauche ich nicht mehr
darüber diskutieren wenn das höchste
deutsche verfassungsgericht bereits 1994
das kommt aus der zeit aus unserer zeit
christiane f christiane f ist am bahnhof
herum gerannt und hat wie viele andere
leute auch vorher geküsst aber andere
leute haben auch vor muttermilch
genossen schokolade gegessen zuckerrüben
übermaß und so weiter dieser
einstiegsdrogen theorie ist nicht mehr
haltbar und sie führt dazu dass da freue
ich mich die führt so ein bisschen dazu
gesagt das ist nicht mehr haltbar ist
also es ist wie eine entschuldigung
haben sie einen wissenschaftler weltweit
selbst die menschen die gegen eine
cannabis legalisierung sind sagen nicht
mehr einstiegsdroge
die haben wir die haben wir wir haben
leute die habe ich auch in meinem
jugendgericht ja die kiffen zu viel aber
ich habe auch ganz viele leute in meinem
jugendgericht die saufen zu viel und
wenn dem so ist dann kiffen hier zu viel
obwohl wir eine provisions politik haben
und da hätte ich in meinen 30 jahren
jugendrichter tun ganz oft mit den jungs
sprechen wollen und zwar offen und
ehrlich wieviel tiefste warum schiffs zu
ist das richtig für dich usw das konnte
ich nicht und das können auch eltern
heute noch nicht weil da ja immer diese
schwerter hängt ja das ist strafbar das
ist strafe das interessiert die
jugendlichen überhaupt nicht ob es
strafbar ist im gegenteil es macht die
sache noch viel spannender
ich könnte ja haben müssen
ich glaube ich werde sie nicht aber ich
bin sehr beeindruckt von ihrem
enthusiasmus für das gras wenn sie
selber gar nicht konsumieren dann ins
ausland fahren das konsumieren wissen
sie denn dann überhaupt die würfe ihr
natürlich war auch jung und dann zwar
bin ich ja bis 34 nicht richter gewählt
natürlich habe ich gekämpft in meiner
schule haben alle gekämpft da sind heute
unternehmer staatsanwälte das sind alles
möglich gewesen für den erfolg finden
sie
produzieren aber da machen das auch
weiter so
okay dass das führt ja auch zuerst ja
warum ich mich engagiere das sage ich
ihnen mein vater hat sich tot gesoffen
mit diesen ganzen geschichten die da
drum herum sind die branche nicht
ausfüllen ja brauche ich nicht mein
bruder hat zeitgleich gekifft war in der
käfer szene über 15 jahre 16 jahre ja
dann hat man stigmatisiert
kriminalisiert und schließlich in den
knast gebracht so und dann frage ich
mich ja hätte man meinen vater nicht in
den knast bringen müssen wir da sein
anwalt mein bruder in den knast gebracht
weil wir ja einen schützenfest mental
bin übrigens mitglied von zwei schützen
vorhanden ja ich war ziemlich droge an
um das nochmal platz als ja ein
betreuungs mittel aber es ist auch eine
allheilmittel für viele vor 5000 jahren
haben dass die alten chinesen lutz
heutzutage 100.000 menschen cannabis als
rezept bevor sie 45 jahre durften sie es
noch nicht mal als rezept unterbrechen
gebeten deswegen würde ich gern
hinterfragen wenn es jetzt legal würden
sie gemeinsam mit herr müller kiffen
die zeit ist vorbei
die zeit also 16 17 ich denke wir haben
alle gekämpft und
natürlich das problem das problem was
sie gar nicht ansprechen ist und das
habe ich gelesen die risiken also
medizinische risiken habe ich gelesen
sind doch da nicht zu unterschätzen also
eine sache
prostatakrebs wird beeinflusst durch
cannabis konsum ich warum wäre warum
nehmen sie das nicht zu erkennen oder
wollen sie das nicht zur kenntnis nehmen
und ist das für sie nicht wichtig also
ich denke da kann man nicht habe weg
deswegen alles wird irgendwie
beeinflusst durch irgendwas wenn sie zu
viel zucker essen wird es möglicherweise
dazu führen dass sie irgendwie zu dick
wird wenn sie dieses oder jenes machen
wird dass jedes mal jedes mittel ja das
wird auch so gesagt nun habe ich aber in
meiner schulklasse waren bald alle am
kiffen und diese enttäuschende
einzelbeispiele
es geht um erziehung und dass wir uns
also bei mir und war das früher so es
gab diese käfer szene und die trink
sehen ja und das eigentlich schlecht er
wir müssen und die und die kinder die
gekifft haben jugendlichen jugendliche
waren die haben dann morgens vor der
schule angefangen zu kiffen ja und da
muss man eigentlich den leuten sagen zu
kämpfen es wie wenn man viel alkohol
trinkt ja das ist beides drogenkonsum
dass man beides betäubungsmittel das ist
beides ernst zu nehmen ja ich kann auch
nicht betrunken in die schule gehen ich
kann mich betrifft in der schule gehen
ja dass man ab und an fährt einmal die
woche ein bisschen mehr trinkt oder noch
gift so sollten wir das glaube ich
verankern und beibringen dass das so
benutzt wird und dann sollen die leute
auch nicht zu irgendeinem dieser gehen
der ihn dann irgendwann einmal gestreckt
ist euch oder anderes zeug geben sondern
was soll man genauso kaufen wir eine
vernünftige falschen die juristen sind
hier wir sind ja auch immer auf dem
boden des grundgesetzes davon abgesehen
ja ich bin alt geschworen ich darf noch
ein wort dazu erstmal danke schön ja
wir haben betrifft in der schule
gesessen die lehrer haben sie haben sich
nicht getraut uns rauszuschmeißen weil
sie angst davor hatten dass diese idee
von ihnen geliebten schüler
möglicherweise sind strafverfahren
bekommt dass das haben sie gerade schön
natürlich gibt es probleme bei dem einen
oder anderen aber diese probleme sind im
verhältnis zu der auch zu den problemen
die durch die prohibition
wer gekommen sind weltweit übrigens
millionen von toten durch kriege und und
unter kampf gegen die drogen ausgerufen
von richard nixon ja
1968 der ist lange verloren und wenn sie
das ins verhältnis setzen ist es so
ähnlich wie ja natürlich ist es herr
müller wenn jetzt noch mal eine frage
wagen ob die frau das geld komplett
überzeugt haben schon nach
ich habe mal mit dem csu müller
wunderbarer mann entwicklung sind
entweder durch
in new york bei lanz gehabt anschlag am
schluss sagte er jetzt bin ich 49
prozent dafür
ja für die legalisierung werden habe ich
gesagt die 51 prozent sind eher csu
geschult ich kann in der sache sagen ich
bin total gegen die legalisierung auch
jetzt noch aber es hat noch nie ein gast
bei 48 so vehement thema vorgenommen
genau erklären werden sie in der
nächsten sendung erkläre mir wäre ja
das höre ich gar nicht so ganz oft das
werden sie auch noch machen die ich
prophezeie es ihnen wenn sie die mittel
ernst wir werden es sehen will auf jeden
fall sind sie sehr enthusiastisch es
gefällt uns hier und jetzt kommen wir
aber gleich noch zu zwei ersten teams
schauen sie - ist auch ein ernstes
trotzdem zeigen schauen sie mal hier ein
teilnehmer einer pro israel demo wird
augenscheinlich von der polizei
festgehalten während er gegen
hassparolen demonstriert und das video
zeigt unseren gast reisen andreas möller
alle hintergründe und dem fahrrad müller
alle hintergründe ist man für die ganz
verrückt durch die tv-debatte alle
hintergründe und die frage ob unsere
polizei verteilt bleiben das wollen wir
gleich nach der werbung beantwortet
etwas gesetzter bis gleichen
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter
brauchen und nicht ernst nehmen als
sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei 14 85 köpfen sind meinungen
jeder von uns hat ein thema mitgebracht
was ihn bewegt freut oder schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht
herr jörges retten das auge ist aber
niemand von den politischen parteien
traut sich zu sagen ja das wollen hier
einfach nur freiheit diese grün-roten
der damen führen hochtrabende debatten
über die rettung des weltklimas und um
die füße russland die ratten das thema
ist viel zu wichtig um es nur derart zu
überlassen lasst den leuten noch mal den
spaß wir sehen da etwas was eigentlich
fatale ist in der politik bei den
journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu finden
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig
durfte
vielleicht einmal kurz einsatz
doch das ist übliche andrack träger aus
abschluss bringen ich habe meinen
beifall über eine sache immer bekommt er
kümmert sich darum niemand ist es was
zählt ist der ganz kleinen auch darüber
sprechen das ist ein fakt nicht fährt
nämlich richtig wohl ist die aufgabe von
journalismus einfach
die verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück beispiel nachts schön
dass sie dran geblieben sind wir machen
jetzt direkt weiter mit dem thema von
ralf andreas müller
dürfen starten will ja mein thema ist
heute
antisemitismus in deutschland wachsender
antisemitismus und ich und meine
mitstreiter in hamburg die einmal im
monat die mahnwache für israel gegen
antisemitismus machen sind der meinung
dass es gut tragbar ist dass in
deutschland wieder der antisemitismus
wächst von rechts von links aber auch
von muslimischer seite dass die
politiker viel erzählen und spiel
ständig hören wir müssen gegen
antisemitismus etwas unternehmen aber
dann wären zum beispiel diese wirklich
israel-feindlichen sogenannten nakba
demonstrationen erlaubt berlin wurde
jetzt letztes wochenende verboten in
hamburg hat die stadt gefunden und in
anderen städten auch zum beispiel hat in
frankfurt die jüdische gemeinde sich
also flehentlich an die behörden
gewendet hat gesagt bitte unterbinden
sie diese israel-feindlichen
veranstaltung wo also gegen israel wo
nicht nur an die nakba den sogenannten
die vertreibung von von arabern 1948
erinnert wird sondern der staat israel
delegitimiert wird wo zu hass gegen
juden aufgerufen wird et cetera et
cetera und
wir sagen es reicht nicht nur
sich aufzuregen sondern wir sagen man
muss auf die straße gehen wir müssen in
deutschland ein zeichen setzen und wir
müssen flagge zeigen das machen wir mit
unserer mahnwache für israel einmal im
monat und
wie sehen da die bilder das ist zum
beispiel von den veranstaltungen die wir
in hamburg hatten und sie haben darüber
berichtet
hierbei btv letztes jahr wir sind
attackiert worden wieder einen
schwerverletzten von muslimen wir haben
jetzt letztes wochenende gegen den
aufmarsch von
von arabern bei dieser demo
protestiert ich bin bedroht worden von
dem veranstalter und von teilnehmen an
dieser nackt war demonstration und stadt
man den veranstalter und die teilnehmer
zur räson bringt hat man mich sozusagen
ja mit aller gewalt wir sehen dass auf
den bildern an die an die an das fenster
dargestellt
ist ging mich vorgegangen hat mich eine
halbe stunde dort festgehalten und ich
denke das ist unmöglich hier wird also
recht umgekehrt aber herr müller wie ist
das möglich sie haben ja danach
wahrscheinlich als sie sich die
situation beruhigt hat haben sehr
wahrscheinlich versucht herauszufinden
warum sie dort dermaßen festgehalten
wurden nein es wurde ja keine begründung
gegeben also ist wurde ich wohl
beschimpft von seiten des veranstalters
dieser demonstration die dort in der
mönckebergstraße stadt fahren und
sofort haben acht beamte sich auf mich
gestürzt ich würde also sehr rabiat
abgeführt es wurde mir angedroht mich zu
boden zu werfen wenn ich mich wäre weil
ich gesagt habe was habe ich getan ich
werde bedroht es gab ja auch zeugen es
gab ja zahlreiche zeugen die das
mitbekommen haben und
mir wurde gar keine gelegenheit gegeben
das zu erklären sondern ich wurde dort
also sehr
unsanft
aus dem verkehr gezogen und übrigens
dann auch das feldes verwiesen also
platzverweis heißt das
nach einer halben stunde es gab eine
kleine gegendemo
dort ein paar meter weiter weg die
wollten wir dann besuchen das wurde mir
verwehrt man über hat gesagt nein sie
müssen gehen verlassen sie den platz und
dann wurde ich raus eskortiert von dem
was sie sagen die polizei darf nicht die
täter schützen wie ist es bei den medien
schützen die zu sehr die täter weil sie
auch oft die täter nicht direkt
ansprechen
wenn du mal ein bisschen vorsichtig die
medien es ist vorsichtig weise selbst
sind nein es gibt solche und solche
natürlich das wissen sie genau so es
gibt nicht die guten oder die bösen
medien sondern es gibt medien die sich
damit beschäftigen und es gibt medien
die bestimmte sachverhalte ausblenden
und das ist bei den printmedien so und
die über die muss man nämlich auch reden
das ist bei den
bei den anderen medien visuellen medien
auch so es gibt man kann nicht sagen die
medien sind schuld aber es gibt schon
finde ich also eine eine grundhaltung
die ein bisschen schwierig ist also da
wo antisemitismus klar zuzuordnen ist zu
nazis zu rechtsextremisten da ist jeder
sich in der verurteilung absolut einig
und da ist die auch ganz schnell da ist
ja auch völlig richtig so mit dem
islamistischen antisemitismus ist es
tatsächlich anscheinend eine andere
sache und das ist glaube ich bei den
ersten jahren nach wird er wird noch
sagen hat und es hat offensichlich an
ähnlichen fall auch in berlin gegeben so
kann man im bild kollegen wo es eben
auch so war das der berichterstatter
dann wäre wiesen wurde statt sozusagen
mal gegen den aggressiven veranstalter
vorzugehen weiß der himmel was die
polizei da nun für motive haben mag das
wäre interessant wenn sie individuell
auch gegen die beamten vorgehen was was
man tun sollte da nicht aber es gibt
auch bei den berichterstattern glaube
ich die angst also ich will kein rassist
zu sein und wenn ich also sagen es gibt
eben auch den islamistischen
antisemitismus dann habe ich natürlich
also kann ich leicht in seinem
fahrwasser geraten aber du bist jetzt
einfach hier generell gegen muslime das
ist natürlich blöd wird darum geht es
überhaupt nicht es geht um eine
bestimmte sozusagen politisch
aufgeladene radikale islamistische welt
sich die fundamental antisemitisch und
am
eigenen geschichte dass wir vielleicht
aber da müsste ja erst recht so zu sagen
und das wäre ja eigentlich auch sensibel
sein was uns wirklich schützend vor
juden stellen es ist auch also sagen mir
jüdische freunde extrem ärgerlich immer
wenn es dann mal ein attentat gegeben
hat einen übergriff irgendwas schlimmes
passiert ist dann stehen sie da relativ
alleine demonstrieren also so viele
leute kommen dann nicht mit sozusagen
von anderen glaubensrichtungen oder oder
auf der atheistischen gesellschaft also
sondern das ist dann eben ihr jüdisches
problem wir glauben es ist nicht so dass
kann man sicher nicht sagen dass jetzt
alle nun hier schon auf gepackten
koffern saßen aber also die jüdischen
freunde die ich habe leiden schon unter
einer verschärften stimmung also die
sind nicht entspannt und die sind nicht
völlig die haben auch nicht das gefühl
dass wir als gesellschaft also an ihrer
seite stehen wie wir das müssen und
darum häufig ein problem mit der
richtung woher und wir müssen wie es ist
ja das problem sie haben es richtig
angesprochen wenn sie sich frau feser
zum beispiel mit ihren stellungnahmen
und
und dem was sie verlautbaren lässt
angucken es geht immer um rechts rechts
die gefahr von rechts ich mache diese
mahnwache für israel seit sieben jahren
seit sieben jahren stehen wir dort
mindestens einmal auf der straße im
monat und es kommen von deutschen
natürlich mal blöde sprüche aber in
diesen sieben jahren haben wir mehrmals
polizeischutz bekommen weil wir von
muslimen das ist keine generalisierung
sondern es sind halt überwiegend muslime
die uns attackieren ja letztes jahr das
waren
menschen mit junge leute mit syrischem
hintergrund ich meine es ist es geht
auch hier nicht um einen generalverdacht
man kann man nicht sagen wenn jemand
jemand umbringt dann dürfen wir das
nicht aufdecken weil hunderttausende
haben keinen umgebracht das ist doch
quatsch man muss die probleme benennen
und wir haben ein neues problem von
muslimischer seite und ich sage und ich
sage es nochmal wir machen diese unsere
mahnwache in verbindung wir haben
persische leute kommen aus dem islam die
neben dran stehen die es sind muslime
aber die haben kein problem mit israel
und die haben vor allen dingen auch kein
problem mit
mit juden und das ist genau das das ist
genau der punkt aber sei eigentlich
selber schön dass es die auch gibt ja
also das ist also das ist doch
eigentlich ein gutes beispiel muss doch
eigentlich sehr positiv dass da auch
menschen aus dem iran stehen und mit
ihnen zusammen demonstrieren und das
anerkennen dass eigentlich er diesen
teil sehr positiv natürlich positive sie
unseren ländern ist es aufrecht man kann
ich das eine gegen das andere auf
positiv erwähnt frauen natürlich eine
frage an sie sie haben ja auch in london
studiert wie haben sie das da
wahrgenommen sie haben verschieden
ländern gelebt wie haben sie es dort
wahrgenommen unterschied zu deutschland
also ich finde in england hat man sehr
andere
sichtweise auf dieses ganze thema wie
sich andere kulturen integrieren es gibt
zum beispiel ganz viele polizisten die
six sind das ist ein
einen stamm also 1 1 es ist eine
volksgruppe aus indien die sind nicht
hinter sondern eine eigene
religionsgruppe und die sind ganz häufig
polizisten das ist aber deshalb möglich
weil sie erlaubt sind ihren kopfschmuck
zu tragen dann trägt man das als
polizist halt ja in london ist das viel
eher so dass man sagt du kannst eine
region mit bringen aber so integriert
und dann haben wir auch sechs die
polizisten sind zum beispiel und dass
wir nicht eigentlich sehr positiv wie
multikulturalismus funktionieren kann
aber in england gibt es eine große
ignoranz gegenüber dem holocaust und und
gegenüber der israel frage das muss man
auch sagen also ich glaube england hat
auch ein massives bildungsproblem
entwickelt in den letzten jahren also zu
sagen ich weiß nicht wie gut die
allgemeinbildung über europäische
kontinentaleuropäische geschichte da zum
teil ist und ich meine gerade die labour
party das war ja besonders erschütternd
und der ehemalige vorsitzende corbijn
hat sich also durch durch also große
ignoranz zumindest daran dass ich noch
mal gelesen jetzt die dörfer genommen
haben wir waren natürlich auch
geschaffen herr müller landen denn hier
in deutschland genug fälle vor gericht
doch ich finde erst mal landen fälle vor
gericht wenn es aufgeklärt wird wenn die
polizei vor ort genau schaut denn dann
auch fälle vor gericht welche fälle von
polizeigewalt oder fälle von
angreifen antisemitischen äußerungen
fälle von verwenden von
verfassungsfeindlichen kennzeichen ja es
wird schon gemacht aber ich sehe im
moment so nicht das große problem da ja
ich seh tatsächlich ich weiß nicht wenn
du in berlin man hinschaute sind aber
meist als problem an natürlich habe er
jahrelang gegen die kämpfte legendäre
sind meine taten gegen rechtsradikale
schläger ich bin auch in der jüdischen
zeitung erwähnt worden oder ganze
berichte darüber gegen antisemitismus
aber
das ist ein problem es waren probleme
und es wird auch natürlich angeles muss
angegangen werden klar und es muss
verhindert werden und ich habe solche
fälle dass leute sollten jugendliche
juden sind an allem schuld und die
wissen ja diversen jude ist und so
weiter da muss gelernt werden aber ich
sehe trotzdem im großen und ganzen ich
finde unsere stadt ganz gut ja ich finde
unser grundgesetz ganz gut trotzdem
trotz des umstands dass ich alles
richtig ist wie bei der cannabis tisch
ich habe noch kein rein spuren
nicht bisher und herr müller haben
jeweils kurzen serie sorgen wir müssen
zum anderen thema kommen jeder hat sein
letztes es ganz gut aber finden sie es
gut dass juden in deutschland nach land
wasser und milan haben wir haben in
berlin die fälle gehabt dass juden keine
keepers tragen darf ich das lebens
gefahren und wir können doch nicht sagen
dass ich bin da eher hart gegen solche
täter vorgegangen man hier herr müller
und hermann nach der seine ausgeben und
jetzt kommt er will mit allen danken wir
den 1 aber jetzt jetzt kommen wir zu dem
thema von einer senftleben uns zwar
deutschlands innovations- schwäche
gefährdet unseren wohlstand genau also
bisschen themen sprung ja hamma
durchschnitt der heckenschnitt aber
trotzdem möchte ich mal so ein bisschen
in die überlegung kommen was passiert
eigentlich wenn es ein land versäumt
innovationen zu fördern und deutschland
hat versäumt innovationen zu fördern wir
haben es verpasst moderne grüne
technologie zu setzen wenn es darum geht
um sich energie zu beschaffen wir haben
uns einfach darauf verlassen dass es
billiges großes weniges russisches gas
gibt dieser soll sind eine
wirtschaftliche abhängigkeit gebracht
und diese abhängigkeit schränkt jetzt
unsere politische handlungsfähigkeit 1
jetzt möchten uns bitten mal den blick
zu weiten und dann sehen wir dass
deutschland auch in anderen bereichen
innovations- schwache ist hier drohen
den anschluss in der nicht nur in der
grünen technologie sondern auch in der
automobilbranche und in der
finanzberichte verlieren nehme man die
automobilbranche als beispiel
jahrzehntelang war deutschland führend
innovationen gingen von deutschland in
die welt deutsche autos sind für ihre
qualität bekannt die letzten beiden
trends haben wir allerdings leider
verpasst und das waren das autonome
fahren und der elektroantrieb mit der
folge dass die autopiloten die software
dafür jetzt in usa programmiert wird die
batterien aus china kommen ja und ich
frage sollen die
zukunftsweisenden fragen wie wir
arbeiten wie wir bezahlen wie wir
kommunizieren wie wir essen wie wir uns
fortbewegen plötzlich wie wir leben
wollen die von anderen beantwortet
werden oder von uns und ich sage wir
müssen die beantworten und dafür müssen
wir zu alter innovationsstärke
zurückfinden wenn wir das nicht tun sehe
ich unseren wohlstand und unsere
freiheit in gefahr bravo
das war sehr gut vorgetragen ich habe
eine frage zu der innovationsstandort du
hast ja hier dein startup mit gegründet
nachdem finn tech startup war es so
schlecht der innovationsstandort
deutschland oder fehlen uns einfach die
kreativen köpfe also hat deutschland die
barrieren gesetzt wie soja unser
standort schlecht also uns fehlen der
standort ist deshalb schwierig weil
europa ganz zersplittert ist ja wir
müssen europaweit einheitlichen markt
sehen im moment haben wir einen
regulierungswut ja billy ist eine finte
unternehmen mehr wir machen innovationen
im bereich wie man im internet zahlt ja
das ist auch wichtig finde ich das in
deutschland machen und nicht auf
chinesischen servern oder auf
amerikanischen servern aber
die denken wir haben ein binnenmarkt
aber es wird trotzdem in jedem land
jeder mitgliedsstaat hat seine eigenen
sondern locken und verhindert dass
letztendlich dass das unternehmer
diesen diesen großen markt als ein markt
nutzen können ja und das ist schon eine
herausforderung noch dazu finde ich dass
wir auch dieses ganze gründerteam
überhaupt nicht als das begreifen was es
ist nämlich wichtig ist wichtig für
unseren standort dass wir startups
fördern dass wir innovation hier haben
ja wir sollten anschließend an so die
alten gründergeist den wir hatten und
und das feiern und nicht immer nur die
digitalisierungs risiken sehen wie man
das doch häufig macht ja
interessant aber natürlich auch ein
demokratieproblem nicht also die
europäische integration in die hängt
natürlich von den mitgliedsstaaten ab
und die haben sozusagen noch nationale
identitäten und interessen und rechts
vorstellungen die sie nicht so leicht
aufgeben und das geht ja wohl nur auf
einem demokratischen weg dass wir uns da
einigen und das heißt das dauert und ist
mühsam das ist sicher mühsamer als in
china trotzdem lebe ich lieber hier wo
sozusagen also den vergleichsweise echte
demokratie herrscht und eben nicht in
einem autoritären in einer diktatur und
ich meine dass das dilemma zum beispiel
bei der energieversorgung es ist ja
richtig also man gleichzeitig aus der
kohle und atomkraft aussteigt dann hängt
man erstmal über öl und gas
für atomkraft kriegen sie keine
gesellschaftliche mehrheit mehr hin
glaube ich obwohl das ja jetzt wieder
verschärfen diskutiert wird und dann ist
natürlich auch das zusätzliche problem
also was ist in schleswig holstein da
gibt es ja schon ganz schön viele
windkraftanlagen uns oder ist die
landschaft schon ganz schön gewaltig
verändert was es nicht gibt sind die
trassen weil die leute keine lust eine
stromtrasse durch ihren garten zu haben
da kommt das klassische nord ein
mahlwerk yard phänomen finde ich auch
ärgerlich dass politik auch viel stärker
erklären diskutieren richtig in clinch
gehen mit den leuten aber es eben nicht
diktatorisch durchsetzen sondern es ist
eben es muss die leute müssen gewonnen
werden dafür soll auf gar keinen fall
diktatorisch durchgesetzt werden ja ich
möchte das weder innovation hier fördern
weil es eben nicht dann irgendwann nur
produkte nutzen möchte die in china
gebaut werden unter einem ganz anderen
werte kann man mit einem ganz anderen
verständnis von datenschutz von
privatheit et cetera deshalb sage ich
wir müssen uns auch an große
infrastrukturprojekte ran trauen und
müssen die durchsetzen und nicht
irgendwie sagen irgendwie anders wird
schon machen und wir können es an
beziehen innerhalb der europäischen
union können und sollten wir es machen
und sollten diesen großen markt auch
nutzen aber wir brauchen das schon eine
wirtschaftliche unabhängigkeit
damit wir uns eben nicht sagen bei uns
machen wir das alles nicht aber dann
nutzen wir dann doch die produkte aus
den autokrat lässt halle für das wort
für unsere sendung wir sind am ende
angekommen herr müller haben auf die
felder
vielen dank und ja denken sie doch mal
über die legalisierung von cannabis nach
schönen abend
[Musik]